My,
my nephew had a dream at one point,
this little,
someone made a little animated thing out
of it and put it on the intranet,
which is quite cool.
So anyways,
he,
he was having night terrors and he ran
around like a little night,
uh,
you know,
Kai,
a Connecticut,
k n I g h t night,
and he had little,
you know,
armor and a sword and he run around the
house with little hat on being the night
and he was only like four or something.
And he'd watched this lot of Disney
movies,
lot of movies.
So he kinda got the night idea was it
was at his acting that out and he was
having these terrors at night,
right.
So He'd go to bed with his little hat
and his sword and he put them on is bad.
And then at night he'd wake up
screaming.
And that happened for a very long time.
And so when I went to visit,
uh,
you know,
I found out that this was happening and
he had a night terror.
So the kid wakes up with night terrors
screaming but can't remember anything.
Generally speaking.
So anyways,
this was happening and so it happened
one day and I was sitting with him and
his family at the,
at the breakfast table,
and I said,
uh,
did you,
did he have a dream?
And he said,
Oh yes,
I had a dream.
I said,
well,
you know,
what was your dream?
And He,
and he said,
well,
I was out on this field and,
and,
and I was surrounded by these dwarfs.
And they came up to my knees and they
were,
they didn't have any arms,
they had big feet and they were covered
with hair and there was a cross shaved
at the top of their head and they were
all greasy and they had huge beaks.
And everywhere I went they jumped at me
with their beaks and there was lots of
them and everybody was very quiet after
he said this because it was like that,
oh,
that's why you're screaming at night.
It's like,
yeah,
okay.
And so,
so,
and,
and then he said,
but,
but at the background there was a dragon
and the dragon would blow out smoke and
fire and then it would turn into these.
Dwarfs,
so it's like,
man,
that kid had a problem,
right?
It was like,
well,
what are you going to do?
We fight off a dwarf.
Who Cares?
It's like plus 10 more.
That's life,
man.
That's life.
Really.
That's the Hydra.
You cut off one head,
seven more grow.
That's life snakes everywhere and you
get rid of one,
there'll be more.
And so he figured that out.
It's a hell of an existential shock when
you're four.
And so he's like,
he's a knight.
He's thinking,
what do I do about these dwarfs while
there's too many of them,
but there's a dragon also.
I said,
well,
what could you do about that?
Right.
Loaded question.
It implies that you could do something
about that.
Well,
he kind of knew that,
which is why he was running around like
a night,
you know,
he kind of figured that out and he said,
well,
I get my dad and I jump up on the dragon
and I poke out both of its size with my
sword,
and then I go right down.
It's stomach to the place where the fire
came out,
the firebox and then I carve a piece of
the firebox Oh,
did I make a shield?
And that would be the end of that.
And I thought,
wow,
good work kid.
Like you really got it right.
It's the,
it's the central human story.
There's the terrible unknown,
right?
Fire-Breathing generating trouble.
And what do you do?
You confront that,
you confront that and by confronting it
you get stronger.
That's the shield and that's,
that's what a human being is.
And that's,
that's right.
It's exactly right.
And that was the end of his night
terrors by the way,
which seems too good to be true,
but it is actually true because I
followed up with his mother for a long
time and that was that he catalyze that
part of his identity.
He adopted the role of the mythological
hero and that's what he needed to do
because like there was lots of drag.
There's a dragon and a bunch of gifts,
like,
what the hell are you going to do about
that run?
That's not gonna help.
You know,
if you run in a dream like that,
the doors multiply and they get bigger
and you get smaller as you run.
It's like that's not a good.
That is not a good solution.
And people do that in their life all the
time and so the dwarves get bigger until
they're giants and they get smaller
until there's nothing left of them and
then then there's no recovery.
That is not good.